what's going on reject nation greg and
john here
never stop never sleeping because the
suicide squad
trailer is officially out it's a red
band baby
yeah shall we wearing a harley quinn
shirt i
told i texted you this morning i'm
wearing harley quinn where's your polka
dot man
where's your javelin shirt they're both
in there
so much i told you i just wear them too
much
there's more characters anywho guys
listen i'm going out of town
uh this sunday so if anything big
happens to drop while i'm gone
i won't be around to cover it anywho
let's watch this
jay mcgonn look at us some pacemaker
what oh i couldn't see you for a second
where'd you go
john please i don't have time for this
banter ugh
gotta continue editing falcon at one
results
[Music]
you were
[Laughter]
back um
i don't know what this looks like it
just really does look like a 70s action
movie
yeah yeah it is
yeah it is
mr pip
yes that is your hand very good
we're all going to die i hope so
thank her
there's a message especially now
all over the beach
[Music]
yeah it just looks like a blast
gotta love the gore man yes
i'm going to get you out of here
uh
awesome possum lady blossom ah looks
like a blast
that looks great that looks great that's
shitty shiny all right
well that looked pretty awesome you
really do get that
dirty dozen team vibe i love how much of
a
fun ensemble this is really feeling like
i know right now this is coming out at a
an interesting
week for dc that i feel like this has to
be said james going to
he did put out a tweet just very
recently saying like i support anything
that david ayer does
i support his work with the whole
movement of the snyder cut and restore
the snyder verse
people were like no we gotta also get
hashtag release the air cut going after
hbo max was like
nope with that in mind though i mean
yeah do i still want an air cut
absolutely but i still think this looks
great
i think it looks so different enough
like
it's so distinguishedly different in
every way
it feels so james gunn and not
guardians of the galaxy james gun this
feels like the older versions of james
gunn
uh that i used to watch you know yeah
before he he started doing comic book
movies for the big studios
yeah exactly those like heart r vibes
but in terms of
uh the ensemble with all these
characters i think they all look great
you know idris elba being established uh
as the leader blood sport
on the team which i find kind of funny
because rick flag is here yeah and then
you think rick flies
yeah you think rick flag would want to
be like the leader and in some ways in
the trailer
he kind of seems like he's the leader of
the suicide squad but i don't know if
rick flag was actually in that scene
where peacemaker did say that yeah maybe
they split up or something into two
units or whatever and bloodsport's just
leading that one
yeah i mean it looks like everyone's
gonna get a chance to shine though
i feel like a lot of the great comedy is
gonna be coming from just blood sport
and peacemaker
interacting with one another this
movie's gonna have to
really let john cena truly shine because
he's got an
hbo series in the works you know he
looks really funny
i'm sure he's going to be very
entertaining he wasn't the one i was
most appealed to
in this trailer they're just weirder
looking ones here
i like round the bat like like savant
like polka dot man just like
i wanted to see especially someone like
a polka dot man i don't want to just see
like what
all that they do yeah because there's so
much possibility and knowing james gunn
you know that
he's probably gonna subvert your
expectations with something that is
you know perfectly in line with the
powers of the character but also
probably tongue-in-cheek or funny or
maybe even crass a little yeah you know
yeah like
the breadth of potential here because it
seems like you know the gloves are off
and they have
room to get wild with it like that's
pretty exciting i'm surprised how much
we
didn't see much of michael rooker savant
i figured like with the amount of times
he's worked with james gunn
seeing his look in the promos he seemed
kind of goofy
like oh it might be a kind of a funnier
character it is like this cyber
criminal martial artist guy right and
then you see him here in the trailer and
you're like oh he looks like the most
serious one he looks like the most
weighty one of them all
you know this trailer almost like an
audience cipher or something because
he's the one getting the explanation of
like if you screw this up we're gonna
blow your head up and everything we
watch him get injected with the chip and
all that i think the woman in the
car or the bus who was talking with
bloodsport that might have been rat
catcher the one yeah when he's like uh
i'll save you and she says no i'll save
you
or something like that i forget exactly
what the line was we only watched
trailer one so
um with her saying that what i'm getting
very excited for is the finale
yeah because i'm thinking that whoever
is standing
by the time the finale rolls around
everyone's going to get a true heroic
moment to shine kind of like with zack
snyder's justice league how
every single individual on that team
truly had a shining moment in that
finale
i'm i'm thinking we're gonna get that
here and i wonder if having that line
from i think that was rat catcher
basically can't control
rats you know super willard super
willard
super willard version but having her
just say that london the trailers make
me wonder if there is a bit of a clue
drop
as to will she be like a big hero
in this journey by the end of it could
be man i wonder if there's going to be
some humor with rick flagg
after being one of the og members of the
suicide squad him or captain boomerang
or something like that
yeah because they have that history and
obviously you know you also have amanda
waller back so
there is i that's a big question mark
for me is how much do we want to
actually acknowledge the previous movie
because also you know you got harley
2 who was directly in that mission with
rick and all that stuff so i think it
would be probably a little bit foolish
just to completely ignore that stuff but
then
i will i feel like you could address it
really quick and move on and no one
would
be really upset about that either well i
i don't think they're going to
uh ignore it the way how this opening
scene was with rescuing harley
um and he's like we don't leave anyone
behind and as like character in the
first one
he was doing his mission but like you're
all a bunch of criminals and thugs and
then here he's like no
i like you it seems like yeah you're my
team i care about you
you're my dorks yeah exactly
but and i wonder if there will be
mention of uh enchantress
in here and all that did we see uh monk
did we see [ __ ] in here at all in the
trailer
i don't i'm not sure i don't i'm not
sure if you see any [ __ ] in here
and maybe point it out for me if you
guys do king shark looks great
and it's so cool how we've got like so
many different iterations of king
shark right now i mean like the cw
version is a lot more
serious and of course you got the harley
quinn version sometimes in the dc
animated version
of the movies they are kind of just like
like a groot but violent
i forget what the line is sorry guys
it's literally two hours
now to be a king shark fan
into the point but king shark looks like
very
violent obviously but also child
like yeah yeah yeah like someone who is
very unassuming in personality but can
rip someone apart when the time comes
and with that strength of like you know
a baby who doesn't know exactly how
strong they are
like that yeah also with uh the star
star oh
that's what it is with the starfish uh
when i first learned about starro it was
because of actually rick and morty
because there's the characters in there
who latch onto the face and control
mines and it was inspired by sorrow i
believe was uh their
rumored taiko white might be the voice
of
sorrow here but it is kind of
interesting because it looks like there
is a
giant super villain in here which will
be star but it's gonna
but because of what starro is it might
be a little bit more comedic
so while the first suicide squad did
have enchantress and sky beams and all
that jazz it was meant to be taken
seriously and people had a hard time
taking it seriously whereas here the
visuals look
great and it'll be i'm sure it'll be
wacky and fun
i don't know i'm just really looking
forward to it guys well this looks like
something that
yeah like learning from the first movie
and some of the foibles of that
this looked more sort of scopically in
line with
what the team is who it's comprised of
what their range of powers is and so it
looks like
at least as of this trailer that this
should kind of crest into something that
ends with a starro finale and that seems
like a character that a bunch of people
with you know
powers that aren't superman level could
still take on
in numbers you know like it is sci-fi
and it is kind of big and over the top
but it's not like
full-on magic wielding where it's like
you know any regular person with a gun
wouldn't
ever have a chance you know and uh they
have peter capaldi here as the
thinker and my my biggest humiliator
my biggest familiarity uh with the
thinker is from
when he was the villain the character
was the villain in the i think it was
season four
of the flash he is a highly highly
highly highly smart man
he's kind of he's got a big iq that guy
yeah his genius level character it seems
like a lot of these characters are being
played here
for comedic effect i wouldn't
underestimate
you know like if if some of these
characters who you might have seen in
other iterations
have more of a bit of a dramatic heft
like thinker like
even king shark and some other pieces of
material
like a lot of these other characters i
wouldn't underestimate that you will
still get to see their powers be
full on display and have the moments of
them where they are super
badass while also having a lot of that
james gun humor i feel like james gunn
would not just chalk them up to jokes oh
yeah i feel like that's the charm of
what you get with james gunn is you'll
get all the irreverent humor
but they'll sneak up on you with some
heart and also some actual
like written and thought out
storytelling yeah man oh yeah
i didn't see much of did we see t like a
tdk is who nathan phillians playing i
could catch him hardly
i mean he's just right here drinking the
pib yeah
harley quinn look guys it goes without
saying we've talked about her plenty of
times over the years margot robbie she
looks incredible as
always it's exciting to see her return
to the franchise where
margot robbie got her start with the dc
universe and james gunn did say
at dc fandom i believe last year that he
was
the person he was actually most excited
to write for was harley quinn yeah you
don't really see much of
boomerang in here either i'm wondering
if he gets killed off may i
wouldn't put it past them i feel like he
gets killed off because
uh he don't really see much of him here
at all in the trailer it looks like it's
pretty clear who the
who the focus of it who the focus
characters are probably going to be
yeah the core team but that's good
because you have a broad ensemble being
teased so it's like that i feel like
there could easily be surprises both in
who gets killed but also who turns out
to be surprisingly important or
prominent or who might you know
show up and have a shining moment to
help save the day or whatever the
impression that i'm getting is that
when it comes down to it the remaining
few of the suicide squad
are probably gonna be peacemaker
polkadot man bloodsport rat catcher
harley quinn
and maybe rick flack like it looks like
wherever they're going
in this latin country yeah
i don't know which one it is wherever in
south america south america in south
america they're going like it looks like
they will be the ones who are the
remaining
uh by the by the time of the finale
which is it's cool because a lot of them
seem like underdogs
and uh also pete davidson pete davidson
here
as blackguard hell yeah i hope i'm not
only
aware that i am watching pete davidson
the whole time
getting lost in the black guard lose him
into that character
and he's gonna move you to tears just
what i guess uh i would end it with this
while you know there are some people
you're like uh he's probably the lead it
doesn't feel as clear
it's like with the last movie as a
little example like clearly will smith
is the lead
of that movie here there's not a real
clear-cut lead like they actually
all feel real ensemble of characters and
it feels like everyone's gonna get an
opportunity to shine and while
some characters will shine more than
others and maybe when we watch it we'll
be like no he's the he's the real leader
she's the real lead right now it's a
true ensemble vibe
uh and that's like the biggest most
important factor i think when doing a
suicide squad movie alright guys well
what did you think of this trailer leave
your thoughts down below subscribe click
that notification bell hit that like
button
we'll catch you guys soon